So far, we've reminded ourselves of
the basics of linear programming
by examining it in just two dimensions.
Then we built up some vocabulary and
notation that allows us to extend
these notions to n dimensions.
Now we're ready for
the culmination of all this work
in the fundamental theorem
of linear programming.
Which captures the idea that optimal
solutions should be at the corners,
also called extreme points
of the feasible region.
And that tells us that we need only
consider basic feasible solutions.
Precisely, the theorem states that given
a linear program in this standard form,
where A is an m x n matrix of rank m.
Then if there's a feasible solution,
there is a basic feasible solution.
And if there is an optimal
feasible solution,
there is an optimal
basic feasible solution.
We'll start by proving the first point.
Let x be a feasible solution, and we'll
consider only the positive entries.
Without loss of generality,
let's assume that those are the first p.
Then it must be the case
that this linear combination
of the columns a1 through
ap is equal to b.
That is after all,
part of what it means to be feasible.
There are two cases.
First, suppose that the columns a1
through ap are linearly independent.
Then it's not possible that
p should be greater than m,
recall that these vectors
are only m elements long.
If p is equal to m, well then x
is basic already and we're done.
P could be less than m,
that would mean that x is degenerate.
But then we can just add columns to
form a linearly independent basis and
we would be all right.
So that then covers the case where
these columns are linearly independent.
Next, suppose that those
columns are linearly dependent.
Well, that means they
are coefficients y1 through yp.
Such that this linear combination of
the columns is equal to 0 with at
least one of the coefficients,
yi positive.
Then we're going to choose this
parameter epsilon in a very clever way.
So that it's the minimum
of these ratios,
xi/yi among all these i's
such that yi is positive.
Then multiplying this
equation by this epsilon, and
subtracting it from this one,
we end up with this equation here.
These coefficients must represent
another feasible solution.
But by our choice of epsilon,
we've set at least one of
these coefficients to zero.
All of the others have
remained positive.
So we've reduced the number
of positive entries in x.
And we can repeat this over and
over until case 1 is reached,
where a1 through ap
are linearly independent.
Now onto part two of the theorem, this
will feel similar to the first part.
We want to show that if there
is an optimal feasible solution,
there is an optimal
basic feasible solution.
We let x be an optimal feasible solution
with non-zero entries x1 through xp.
Well it's feasible,
so this linear combination of the
columns of a then must be equal to b.
And because it's optimal,
it's objective value,
c transpose x must be the maximum
over all possible feasible x.
Again, we first consider the case
where the columns a1 through ap
are linearly independent, and
the situation is the same as before.
P being greater than m is impossible,
equal means that it's a basic solution,
and less just means that
it's a degenerate solution.
This case is simple.
If these columns are linearly dependent,
then there exists a set of
coefficients y1 through yP.
Such that the linear
combination of the columns
is equal to 0 with at least
one of the y's being positive.
Note however, for epsilon sufficiently
close to zero in both the positive and
the negative direction.
X minus epsilon y is still feasible.
Multiply epsilon times this equation,
and add it to this equation, and
we end up still with a set
of coefficients equal to b.
Thus, c transpose y
has to be equal to 0.
If it weren't, then c transpose
x would be strictly less than
c transpose times x minus epsilon y.
We can choose the right sign on epsilon,
so that this inequality holds.
But this is impossible
because x is optimal.
We conclude that c transpose
y is equal to 0 and
then we can choose epsilon to be
the same thing we chose it before.
It'll still give us
an optimal feasible solution,
only this time it will
have smaller support.
Because we're able to choose it
to set one of the coefficients of
this vector here to zero,
that wasn't zero before.
And we can repeat playing this game over
and over until we've reached the case
where a1 through ap
are linearly independent.
We've just seen how the fundamental
theorem of linear programming
tells us that we can always
achieve an optimal value for
the program with a basic solution.
Moreover, basic solutions come
from the choice of m linearly
independent columns for the bases.
Remember this key point going forward.